انا لست خادمتك بهذه الكلمات تلقنت مضيفه
طيران درسا لمسافر بعدما واجه اهانه لطاقم
الطائره بسبب وجبه طعام حيث انتشر مقطع
فيديو على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي هذا
التعاطف واعجاب الملايين من رواد مواقع
التواصل عند ما احتدم النقاش بينهما على
متن رحله من اسطنبول الى نيودلهي
سوف جابوني
مقطع فيديو تداوله رواد مؤقت التواصل
الاجتماعي للسياره احترقت في منطقه بعبدا
في لبنان وسط فشل محاولات المراه في انقاذ
المراه التي كانت تقودها ودفاع اللبناني
يخمد النار ويستخرجوا الجثه دون ذكر سبب
الحريق في مذكره وسائل اعلام المحليه انها
سبب ان سبب انفجار اسطوانه الغاز
[موسيقى]
انفقت سيده نمساويه اكثر من خمسين الف
دولار على عدد ضخم من عمليات التجميل مثل
فيلاري الشفاء لتتحول الى هيئه تشبه
الدميه باربي مشيره الى انها ليس لديها
نيه للتوقف عن عمليات التجميل وقالت بيتي
اني شفتاي الضخمتين قد تم حقنهما بحوالي
50 الى 60 حكمه فالناس اما يحبونها او
يكرهونها وانعمه بها
ناول الرواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
مقاطع فيديو لمعتمرين وهم يقطفون حول
الكعبه في مكه المكرمه تحت زفات المطر
انتشر مقطع فيديو ايضا لحفل تخرج تحول الى
كارثه اثناء احتفال الطلاب بتخرجهم في
بيرو حيث انهارت حلبه الرقص بهم بشكل
مفاجئ ومخيف نحن نتابع
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم